i'd rather just date my friend to be
honest
okay that was too honest
hi i'm esther pavitsky and i'm a
stand-up comedian and actress and today
we're decoding girl language
[Music]
i don't think women should always go to
the bathroom together because i i the
word always in general it's like
you never know
i don't do a lot of stuff alone i really
don't i want to be clear but go to the
bathroom
i can do that alone now
okay so if you want to stay out but your
friend is ready to go
stay
definitely don't be the jerk that's like
you have to stay no just go be like
you're free to go love you
see ya i'm going to stay here and then
go out for waffles at 4 a.m and yeah
i'll be more bloated than you when we
wake up but worth it
[Applause]
[Music]
if there's only one nacho left and
you're at dinner with me i'm getting it
no matter what i don't care who you are
i don't care unless you're my dog no she
can't have nachos that's getting crazy
i'm having the nacho
[Music]
if your friend's outfit isn't a vibe
girl you tell her okay
honestly i want a friend to tell me
because then i could just be like well
you're wrong and we can like really talk
it out start that conversation here's
how i feel here's how you feel
communicate sure it'd be easier to just
be like cool outfit but that's boring
and we want chaos baby
[Music]
i think it's okay to post an instagram
where your friend doesn't look great as
long as you don't ask them first because
if you do ask them first they're not
going to let you so just post it and be
like oh i thought you looked good i'm so
sorry i guess i just think you're so
pretty
[Music]
always save a stranger if they're being
hit on by a creepy guy honestly i think
that's a law and if it's not it really
should be i always try to check on my
girls if i'm out like even if i don't
know you i'm just like
are you okay
and then usually they're totally fine
and they just think that i'm trying to
get with that guy
but um i'm not i know i don't have a
chance with him that creepy guy i i
don't have a chance
my friends are like family to me and it
just kind of is creeping me out you know
i'd rather just date my friend to be
honest
okay that was too honest
i always take back the friend who
abandoned me for a guy just because like
i've been there
you know the first year of a
relationship i kind of always assumed
that i'm not going to hear from my
friend for a while but then i know that
if it's a good relationship at the end
of the year they're going to be better
than ever and they're going to be
excited and bored with their boyfriend
so we'll get even more fun time
well there's some unsolicited advice for
you please don't sue me and you can
catch my podcast trash tuesday on
youtube
[Music]